[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Thank you so much
for coming to the AI Huddle.
If you don't know
what AI Huddle is,
it's Google Cloud's
open collaborative
and developer-first forum
with Google AI expertise.
And our whole goal is to
connect Google's AI expertise
with developers and customers
who are running their AI
workloads, preferably on GCP.
And the goal is to have
conversations with you
around AI, what problems
you are trying to solve,
and, basically, learn more
from your experiences,
and have a dialogue, have an
exchange of ideas and thoughts.
So with that, I will--
actually, let me
do a quick intro
of our speaker for tonight.
SPEAKER 2: [INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 1: OK.
I got-- I got [INAUDIBLE].
OK, cool.
So our speaker for
tonight is Yu-Han,
who is an engineer
in Google Cloud AI.
Yu-Han-- let me take out--
Yu-Han is a developer,
program engineer
in Cloud AI since 2017,
and previously, he
worked as a machine
learning engineer
and full-stack engineer
at multiple startups.
So with that, I
will hand it over
to Yu-Han, who is going to do
a deep dive in the TensorFlow
topic.
YU-HAN LIU: Thank you.
Thank you, and welcome.
I would like to talk to you
a little bit today about how
to use TensorFlow in Docker.
It's not a new topic.
I suspect many of
you might already be
doing this for your workflow.
If that's the case,
there might still
be one or two things
that's interesting for you
to care about today.
And I made this very
clear, that I'm really
talking about how to run
machine learning workflow
more efficiently,
in a sense slightly
different from the
usual way, and people
talking about, you're mentioning
your workflow, the efficiency.
And we're talking about
your own development cycles.
I'll share a few personal
stories in my previous machine
learning work, and
how that impacted me,
and how I wish I had used
Docker with a better habit,
and that would probably
save me a whole lot of time.
Just in case, maybe some of you
have not used Docker before.
Maybe you heard about it
but haven't gotten into it
just yet.
Docker's really all about
dependencies, in one
word-- just dependencies.
And that's a way for you to
declare and pin dependencies
in a really, really nice way.
How does that have to do
with TensorFlow or machine
learning workflow in general?
I would like to sell
you this vision.
When I think about a
project that's being done,
there are just three components
I usually think about.
One is the developer--
that's you--
who is usually writing the code.
And that's the code, in one of
the corners of the triangle.
But that code doesn't
just run in a vacuum,
but rather, it runs on some
kind of infrastructure.
There's some environment
that supports
the code that can be run.
And that environment,
in turn, has been set up
by you, again, the developer.
And so that's the triangle here.
Now, if you are a single
developer on a one-person
team-- that's yourself--
working on a single project,
a single code base, in an
always-consistent environment--
say, your laptop--
then, probably, you
don't need Docker,
to be completely
honest with you.
But any moment, if any
of these three corners,
I guess, of the
triangle changes,
Docker might help
you in some ways.
That's the pitch I have tonight.
So you can imagine, how can
the developer corner change?
Well, you might need
to share your project
with someone else on the team.
If I'm working on a
multiple-person team,
maybe you need to hand
it off to your engineer
if you are in the role
of a data scientist.
Or the code-- you might be
working on multiple projects
at the same time.
You might be maintaining
and, in fact, improving
more than one
machine-learning-based services
in your production
environment at the same time.
Environment-- you might be doing
experimentation on your laptop
in, maybe, notebooks or some
other kind of configuration,
and you do want to move
it to the cloud somewhere
for serving, or for
larger-scale training.
And so that is when you have
a change in the environment
angle of the triangle.
And so whenever any
of these changes,
you might be in a situation
of dependency inconsistency.
And so that's when
Docker might help you.
But I do want to
point out that Docker
isn't the only solution for
any of these problems, right?
There are other ways
to deal with this.
For example, normally, for
users who do need to work on--
for developers who need to
work on multiple projects
in the same environment and be
local on your local machine,
usually, people will go
with a virtual environment--
say in Python.
And most programming
languages nowadays
have some form of dependency
management tools for you.
So that is sort of handled.
And environment as well--
there are many different ways
to migrate from one
environment to another
without all kind of headaches
that I hope to tell you
a little bit about tonight.
But Docker happens
to be a sufficiently
flexible and powerful
tool that handles
all this in a consistent way.
And so the kind
of good habit I'm
hoping to promote
in this session
is that, with a fairly
small amount of overhead,
when you set up a project and
when you work on a project,
you'll be able to remove some
of these obstacles later on.
If you foresee that,
there'll be a point in time
when I need to hand this
project off to someone else,
or even just start
collaborating with someone else,
or if you see that
at some point,
you want to smoothly switch
between different projects
or move to different
environments,
you might consider starting
out with a good habit.
And this is really general about
software development projects
and not specific about
machine learning workload.
But honestly, a lot of times,
machine learning workloads
have this hidden dependency that
people don't talk enough about,
in my opinion.
So in my own example,
in a previous team,
I had worked on machine
learning projects back-to-back.
Back then, we used scikit-learn.
And I deployed one
model-- so great.
And then, when I moved on to
the next project, I thought,
I will be upgrading my
scikit-learn version,
and then to use a
new feature which
I needed for the next project.
So it saves me a lot of time.
Only, when I deployed
that, I realized
I was breaking the
previous project
because the previous
project could not
be loaded into a newer
version of scikit-learn.
And I don't know if this
has happened to you.
For TensorFlow, I had the
exact same issue as well.
I had old checkpoints trained
with the older version
TensorFlow.
It just does not load for me
anymore with a newer version.
And so you can imagine, if
you're a data scientist working
in this situation, you might
have deployed a whole model
somewhere already, and the
requirement has changed,
or the need has arisen so that
you need to improve the model.
You would like to load the
old checkpoint without having
to redo all the experiments.
It doesn't work
anymore because you've
uploaded-- so you have updated
your TensorFlow version.
So that can be very subtle,
because these things are really
hard to pin down.
A lot of times, people will
go with [? PEEP ?] requirement
files and say, this is a list
of key packages that's needed.
And that's what we did
before, at the previous team.
Only when we realized that we
were using a single requirement
file for that a single
one monolithic code base,
and that's causing
problems for everyone who's
using the same code base,
because I'll be saying,
hey, guys, I need to update this
particular scikit-learn version
to a fancier version
because I needed it,
and that breaks anyone else's
work because they can't use it.
And that particular
case happened
because scikit-learn was making
a very significant change.
They moved a bunch of code from
pipe down into Java back-end.
And so that caused
a whole lot issues
because some interfaces
suddenly disappeared.
We do hope that similar
things will not happen to you,
but if it does, it'll
be a lot of headache.
And the end result
was something like I
had to spend a whole
month trying to figure out
what's the update path
for the whole code base
so that no project
will break, I can still
use a new feature I want,
old models can still
be deployed to production.
A lot of problems.
And so these are the
benefits of Docker,
exactly corresponding to
those three kinds of changes
I was talking about.
For consistency-- if
you want to run code
in the exact same environment,
Docker helps you do that.
For isolation-- if you want to
work between different projects
with very quick switch,
yes, virtual environment
is super fast too in terms
of switching projects.
Docker can do that as well.
Collaboration is really
the bigger piece here.
And by "collaboration,"
I mean a little bit more
than code-level collaboration.
A lot of times, you
do need to hand off
a whole deployable project,
a bundle of some sort,
to your engineer, and then
you'll deploy that to somewhere
on your infrastructure.
And Docker makes
this much, much more
seamless because the
environment that is, first
of all, declared in an
understandable way-- that's
really important-- and
making the results much more
reproducible.
So I want to--
just for the benefit
of those who may not
have been using
Docker for a while,
I have a little bit of a
mini cheat sheet here showing
some of the commands
I'll be using today
for I think, in a
few minutes now,
I will switch into more,
like, a light demo mode
and show you one
particular workflow.
So illustrating all these
points I was making here.
So the base is Docker.
There's these two things
that are often confused.
There's a Docker image
and a Docker container.
A Docker image is
just-- you should
think of that as
software bundle that
comes with the dependencies
already installed in there.
And the container is a
running instance of that.
So the same image could
be run multiple times.
So you could have one
image being run five times
and get five
different containers
all running the same image.
So think of them
as five processes
running the same code, and so
these are some basic commands.
You can pull an image that
people have published.
For example, here I'm
showing a standard way
to identify a Docker image.
So GCR stands for
Google Cloud Registry.
It holds Docker images for
you, so you can pull it
if you will have built and
published Docker images,
and you can--
docker space images basically
lists all the images
you have pulled
from repositories.
rmi stands for Remove Image.
That's really handy.
There'll be a time when you
have way too many Docker
images on your laptop, and
you may want to remove them.
And to run them, you
basically use the same syntax.
Also, by the way, here, whenever
I mentioned REPOSITORY:TAG,
that's the same thing up there.
So that whole thing, gcr.io,
everything after colon is,
in Docker language,
called the repository.
And after the colon is the tag.
And so you might be
pulling different things,
like different versions.
And if you have a
container that's running,
you can kill it.
Again, Docker container is--
you should think of that
as the running process that
runs a specific piece of
binary, perhaps, or executable.
We should think of it that way.
Questions so far?
Good?
OK.
A little bit more.
And Docker file is
really the declaration
of how to build the image.
We're going to go
through a really
baby example of that today.
And then, these next two
things are really interesting.
I'll make some more
points in a minute.
Like a mount value--
so a Docker container
is a process
that's running on a host
machine, maybe on my laptop.
So what happens is
that, on the base
here, that my laptop has
its own operating system,
and on top of that, it could
be running multiple Docker
containers at the same time.
So those are called Docker
containers processes
running on top of the host.
And so there's the way
to communicate the host
and the container themselves.
And these are two basic ways.
One is by mounting
a volume if you
want to share part of your
host disk with a process--
which is extremely important.
I'll get to it in a minute.
And another way is
to forward a port.
So maybe your container
is running a service,
and by exposing some kind
of port on the container,
you do want the host to
be able to access that
from outside of the container.
And that's how the
way you will just
forward a host, port number,
colon, a container port number.
So it's the same syntax--
host container ordering.
With all the other nice things
I could say about Docker,
there are a few gotchas.
And so one of the most
important things--
I cannot emphasize this enough.
I tried.
I have all capital, bold
italic font, and in highlight.
Everything you're doing in
a container will be gone.
Again, will be gone.
I've seen this happening
to new Docker users
and experienced users as well.
They go into Docker,
they feel so at home,
and they run all kinds
of downloaded stuff,
install things, and run code,
they save a model locally.
And then, they exit the process.
All that is gone.
So the interesting thing is that
a Docker container feels just
like a shell, right?
You can connect to it.
It's a process that's
a whole environment,
It feels like a new
computer, almost.
You can do all kinds
of things in it.
It even has a file
system in there--
except that file system
is not persistent.
The moment you exit the
container, everything is gone--
unless you were doing things
carefully and connected
the running container with
a host in the first place.
Now, everything you were writing
into the disk in a container
does get returned
to your host disk.
That way, it'll not be gone.
And so that's really one
of the biggest gotchas
I have wasted hours to recover
work just because of this
until I learned
how to mount disks.
But think about this--
there's a downside
of mounted disks,
because it means
your package has
some additional extra
dependencies there.
So you are mounting a disk, and
you download things, write code
happily, but all that code is no
longer in the Docker container.
So that means this Docker
container or image thing cannot
be handed off easily anymore
because now it has to carry
this additional baggage
of whatever code, or data,
or model that you have
created on the side.
So that's some trade-off
you need to think about.
Normally, I would
recommend doing things
with some of the cloud storage
on day one, if you can.
If you foresee that
eventually that's
going to be your need
anyway, start writings things
to a cloud somewhere.
That way, you and your
team can easily share that.
Another thing
that's also gone is
that you connect into your
Docker instance, and then
a process, and then
you install things.
It will also be gone.
And then you come around, and
your code, again, somehow it
doesn't work anymore.
It's complaining about
some packages missing.
You say, wait a second,
I've installed that before--
only, you have
exited the process.
And so here, Docker
provides a handy way for you
to sort of remember to
keep a note for that,
is through the mechanism
of a Docker file.
So every when you are in
a container and install
something, make sure you record
that in your Docker file.
That way, you'll never be lost,
and then everyone-- anyone--
can come and reproduce that.
Some other gotchas that we'll
not really get into today
is networking.
It's a little tricky.
That has to do with the
port forwarding business
we mentioned before,
because Docker's containers
are designed to be--
one of the goals is
to be really secure.
So we don't really
want containers
to be talking to
the outside world
very easily, for good reasons.
And so sometimes,
people have struggled
with networking a little bit.
If you are in a
situation where you
do have to manage a
large number, even just,
in any case, the
multiple containers that
need to talk to each other or
the outside world and the host,
that becomes a really
complicated graph.
You might consider using
some frameworks that help
you do that such as Kubernetes.
There are some other
tools out there, too.
And credentials is
another issue as well.
On your laptop, you just
just happily connect
to any kind of services that
you are authorized to use.
But in a container,
it's usually running
in a different identify, right?
Remember, that's like
a whole new computer
that happens to be running
on your host machine.
It might know nothing whatsoever
about your host machine's
credentials or
environmental variables,
and things like that.
So there are issues
there, as well.
But we'll probably not
get into that today.
OK, any questions
up to this point?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: What is
Docker Compose?
YU-HAN LIU: Docker
Compose is the--
I don't know, what
do you think is this?
AUDIENCE: I don't know.
We just used it in the
morning, at [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: It's based
on the [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Is it simpler
than the container?
YU-HAN LIU: I've not
used that before.
I've heard of good and
bad things about it,
That's all I can say.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: I don't know.
Does anyone know what
Docker Compose do for you?
AUDIENCE: Well,
maybe [INAUDIBLE]..
YU-HAN LIU: Maybe not.
We could look it up together.
AUDIENCE: Yes, please.
YU-HAN LIU: There was another
question, or a comment?
AUDIENCE: When you download
Docker, [INAUDIBLE],,
is there like a
GitHub [INAUDIBLE]??
YU-HAN LIU: There's something
like that, too, yes.
Thank you.
So you just pull from,
typically, public repositories,
very much like GitHub.
And in fact, there's
something called
Docker Hub that has published
Docker images that to download.
So you can download
individual images from there.
So for reasons, I was just in
a the suite for a TensorFlow
session earlier.
And then they mentioned
Docker's [INAUDIBLE],,
and then, you can actually
go to [INAUDIBLE] repository
and download a Swift Docker.
And that way, you can run
things on your local machine.
That's right, so there's
something like that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is it really possible
to do incremental updates
of Docker images as a team
with everybody [INAUDIBLE],,
instead of downloading the
whole image every time,
is there a way to [INAUDIBLE]?
YU-HAN LIU: Yes, yes.
So the question was, how do you
do, like, incremental update
of Docker images?
Yes, when you build
a Docker image,
it eventually has this
concept of layers.
Usually, you can ignore
that because Docker,
the software, Docker
itself handles that for you
in saying that it caches, right?
You are building an
image, which really
means you start somewhere,
a starting point,
and then start
adding dependencies
to it which your project needs.
And eventually,
adding your code that
has to be executed on top
of all that dependency,
you're not really downloading
everything every single time.
We'll see that in a bit.
So parts that have
been downloaded once
will be cached on
your system somewhere,
and then next time, when
you build on top of that,
you'll not be
re-downloading again, OK?
But that's handled
for you automatically.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: Sorry, come again?
AUDIENCE: Do you
require a license
to run Docker, [INAUDIBLE]?
YU-HAN LIU: Oh, for Docker, or--
AUDIENCE: For the
software inside it.
YU-HAN LIU: Oh inside of Docker?
I think for a lot of times--
so I think yes if you're in--
you're saying using
software in the Docker image
the has license?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So [INAUDIBLE] if I give
my software [INAUDIBLE]??
YU-HAN LIU: Mm-hmm.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: Yeah, I think, at
least, if you publish things
on a Docker Hub, you
have an opportunity
to put in your license
there to specify that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: OK, so the kind
of workflow I wanted to really
quickly show today is that, how
would I go from experimenting
locally and develop a simple
machine learning model--
or workflow, rather?
And you see, I was trying
to do the things carefully
on the local level.
Even locally, I don't just
run on my host machine,
but rather, I already do it
inside of Docker container
environment so that
later, I can literally
lift up this whole Docker and
then move it somewhere else,
exact same result
will be repeated.
Just remember that I have
to save my work in a volume,
and then I will
try to show you how
to build a really simple,
minimal Docker image.
And if we have time--
I suspect we might run out--
we might show how to
deploy this container,
deploy this images container
somewhere, to do training, OK?
Let me exit here from the slide.
OK, so my starting point is that
I need to start with something.
I need to start with a
Docker image that has
some stuff that I would need.
So I'm just going to use an
example I mentioned before.
So Google Cloud already
publishes some of this.
So I'm going to run a
local container workflow.
I'm just going to take
this because that already
has Notebook
installed for me, so I
can run Notebook
experiments, which
I feel more comfortable in.
And a bunch of stuff, skip over.
And here's a key point here.
How do I know what
kind of Docker images
are out there that
I can download?
Here's one place
where I can actually
get a list of one
particular repository
and see what kind of images
this particular repository has
included.
So I'm going to just run that,
and it lists a bunch of them,
right?
So I see some PyTorch
Docker images.
I see some R images.
I see TensorFlow
images, and compiled
with different flavors.
And so those are
packaged environments.
I can-- is it visible?
Maybe I can make
it a little bigger.
Does that help?
OK?
So I can just Docker
pull one of those.
I'm going to pull the
2.0 CPU image today.
So I'm going to copy
this identifier here,
and sometimes you can
add a colon with a tag
there if you know
which tags they are.
And I'm just going
to pull the latest.
So in this case, I'll be
running docker pull and exactly
that identifier there.
And it's going to use
a default tag latest.
Then it says, it's done.
Well, let me be honest with you.
This normally takes a while,
because that image is actually
six gigabytes in size.
So you take some time for
the first time you run it,
but subsequent runs
will not require
you to re-download that again.
So it already saves
a copy of that.
And yes, I can also run-- one of
the commands was Docker images.
And you will see a
bunch, because I have
been playing with this before.
But-- and as we do see that, it
shows up somewhere right here--
this one here.
So that's one that I already
pulled three weeks ago,
and it's in size it's
a scary six gigabytes.
And when I look at this list of
images, I was kind of worried,
right?
Whoa, I have a whole bunch of
images, each one of them listed
as six gigabytes.
So I guess something like
a 6 times 20 of a bunch.
But that's not the case.
All those individual
images are six gigabytes,
but they do share
the cache layer.
And so if they all come
from the same base image,
that base image is no longer
repeated in different images,
all right?
So Docker handles that
for you really nicely.
OK, so I have this.
What do I do?
I'm going to follow
instructions here and say,
here's the way to run it.
And actually, run one
of the images here,
documentation shows 1.13.
I'm not going to run that.
I'm going to run
2.0, and I'm going
to mount the volume as well.
So let me copy this
and then modify it.
So I don't want to
run this command,
but instead of 1.13,
I'm going to run 2.0.
And I do want to
forward the port.
If you see the 8080 port,
that's the default port
for JupyterLab.
And I want to mount the volume.
I'm not going to
mount this path local.
I'm going to mount it as--
I'm going to mount them
on my current directory,
and the [INAUDIBLE].
OK?
I'm going to run it.
And by the way, you also see--
oh, image not found.
Did I maybe not have the right--
oh, I see.
I think they changed
the name on me.
Because I'm going
to run-- now, again,
copy this to make sure I
don't, maybe, type it in wrong.
There, OK.
Now it just spits out a
hash, which is of no use.
And somehow I'm returned
back to my shell.
I can do things now here again.
What happened is that, because
we have a dash d in there,
it's in the detached
mode, or daemon.
So the image will try to run,
and if it exits, it exits.
But in this case, it does not
exit because the way this image
is built, it turns
on the server.
That's now 8080.
Because of port
forwarding, I now
can access that service,
that the JupyterLab server,
there's going to run
inside of the container
through my host, which means my
browser can just access that.
And this mounting here means
it connects whatever directory
I'm in with the home
directory inside of Docker.
So let's do some experiments.
And I have a few, a
couple of files here.
I'm going to make a fake file.
I'm making a new file here
called deleteme, in here,
and I'm going to connect
to my JupyterLab.
localhost:8080, and there it is.
And on the left-hand side, I
see the exact same three files.
So it's showing up right
here, including the one
I just made, "deleteme."
And so to just prove to you
that these are really connected,
so just to make sure-- and
that's also a good habit
to have to make sure that
I don't lose code here--
I'm going to come outside here.
Remember, this shell window
here, terminal window here,
is in the host environment.
I'm not in Docker there.
I'm not in Docker container.
But right-hand side,
the JupyterLab,
I'm instead of Docker.
So it's another machine
that's running in here.
I'm going to remove deleteme,
because it says that.
So I'm going to come back
here and then refresh,
and it's gone again, OK?
And so this really validates
that these two volumes
are connected--
one on Host, which I know is
persistent, and the other one
on the Docker container
that would have been gone
if I would exit the process.
But because we mounted
a volume, that's OK.
And right now, I'm going
to stimulate development--
maybe developing an
experimentation for a model.
I'm going to just clone.
I'm going to go to home
first so I see the same file.
So this is the home inside
of Docker container now.
There's another machine
that shared the disks.
And I'm going to just clone
this repo, this TensorFlow
examples that contains a lot
of community goodies in here.
So I'm going to
give Chrome that.
OK, so we're done the
shadow Chrome, but it's OK.
OK, we got it.
So now I get that thing again.
If you still don't believe
me, I'll come outside here--
oh, it's not done--
and I'm going to list the files.
Now I see the directory examples
now has been cloned, also,
onto my host.
That's my laptop here, OK?
And there's one
particular notebook
I would like to experiment with.
So let me say--
let me just copy it out.
Sorry, copy example.
Let me try and make this bigger,
see if that's more visible.
There.
I'm going to copy
one of the files
out so I can work with it.
I don't have to
always go so deep
into the inside of the repo.
So community, I'll have English.
I'll take this
autoencoder notebook,
and I'll copy it outside.
Of course, it shows
up right away--
almost right away.
I opened Python 3
Notebook with it.
And so I get this code here.
Now, again, it's
running not on my--
well, technically, yes,
it's running on my machine,
but it's running inside the
environment that's completely
contained in a container.
I'm going to run all to make
sure that everything works.
Questions to this
point, by the way?
AUDIENCE: So the
only access to Docker
is through a web browser?
YU-HAN LIU: There are
other ways to access.
The question is, how--
so the Docker container,
what are the ways I can access?
I can do it in the browser,
because I have exposed--
I have run, I'm running
a Jupyter service
on the Docker
container, and that
has been forwarded to my host.
There are other ways
to do that, as well.
From my terminal window, I can
actually SSH into it as well.
Sort of SSH.
Not really SSH.
Rather, just I could just
connect to is directly.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: You can.
That's what you can do.
So for example, you can
see a little bit here
and here, this is the shell
that's surround on the Docker
container.
You can do it from
terminal directly as well.
So if you know what is already
installed on the Docker
container, you can do
whatever you need on it.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are the Docker
containers now [INAUDIBLE]??
YU-HAN LIU: Yes, I think so.
I think-- well,
what do you mean?
AUDIENCE: Like, when
I run my, you know,
[INAUDIBLE] with a number of
my downloaded [INAUDIBLE]..
YU-HAN LIU: Mm-hmm, this
[INAUDIBLE] GPU, right?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: Yes, but--
but there's some work.
So just tell me about streaming
other kind of resources.
Like mounting a
volume is sharing
the disk, that's a file
system, without the container.
And sharing other resources
can be a little problematic.
I think GPU, yes,
is something I'm
sure is a solved problem,
because I know that Kubernetes
can do that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Yeah we
only support Linux.
AUDIENCE: Only Windows?
AUDIENCE: No we only support
Linux. because [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: There are ways that
you can do it with Windows, but
[INAUDIBLE].
YU-HAN LIU: Thank you.
Also, there are other
kinds of resources
you might want to share
that's, also, very problematic.
For example, you
might try to share
the microphone of your host
with a Docker container.
That can be very hard to do.
So, but I mean, there's a way.
There's a path
forward, to be sure.
Other questions or comments?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How do you get
a shell container when
you're [INAUDIBLE]?
Because it didn't
change [INAUDIBLE]??
YU-HAN LIU: You mean
the one on the right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
YU-HAN LIU: The one on
the left has not changed.
The one on the left has
not changed because I
was running in detached mode.
So that docker run command--
let me go back here for a bit.
So it was saying,
run it, and then
let me go back to
my old shell, right?
So it has not changed, right?
I'm still in my own
TF in Docker shell,
still on my host machine, right?
AUDIENCE: So how did
the files [INAUDIBLE]??
YU-HAN LIU: The
files are connected
through this mount,
sorry, the dash v command.
This dash v here
stays right now,
this directory I'm in, where
I run docker run command,
I want this directory to
be shared with the home
directory inside it.
And so it's like two different
processes somewhat have
a shared memory of sorts, OK?
AUDIENCE: OK, so is
that [INAUDIBLE]??
YU-HAN LIU: That's right.
Exactly, exactly.
So now everything I do
inside the container
will be persisted
on my host disk.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: Sorry,
what was the last part?
AUDIENCE: If you're
wanting to do [INAUDIBLE]??
YU-HAN LIU: Is the
question that if you
have used another
container and they're
sharing the same volume?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
YU-HAN LIU: That still
works, because that somewhat
goes through the host.
AUDIENCE: Right.
YU-HAN LIU: Probably
not recommended, though,
so unless you're
fully in control
of what all the
different containers are
doing with the mount.
But yes, it does work.
AUDIENCE: It'll take you to
your home directory [INAUDIBLE]??
YU-HAN LIU: Right, and you can
mount this exact same directory
on my host with something else
with another container, that's
right.
And so that would
be, physically,
still the same disk, but then,
the containers, remember,
they are really just processes.
They can access those
at the same time still.
Except, when you're
inside a container,
they will look like
some local directory.
AUDIENCE: Right,
and [INAUDIBLE]??
YU-HAN LIU: That's
right, that's right.
So that's why it's so important.
That's why, so things
will not be gone.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: Yeah, but
it kind of depends
on what you're trying to
do with things, right?
I mean, because then
you start in a situation
where you might have race
conditions, or you think about,
do I need to lock this file so
that, you know, this container
is accessing it, what if the
other container is also trying
to do something about it?
Things like that.
But yes, in principle,
you can do that, but then
you need to think about
coordinating this.
That's what I mean.
If you have full control of
what the containers are really
doing, no problem.
But if you're not sure, right?
You might have
something that's, say,
running training and writing
output checkpoints to a disk,
and then have another process
doing evaluation, for example,
something like that.
That actually
totally makes sense,
because you're you
will not have, like,
a race, the right conditions.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can I just
collab [INAUDIBLE]??
YU-HAN LIU: Collab?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: When you say collab,
you mean like this collab?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: Depends on
your use case, I think.
So in this case, I think the
collab instances are gone
after a certain amount of time.
So you'll need to
need to somehow put
things in different places.
It can be a little harder
to install dependencies,
for example.
Like here, you come to a
specific version of TensorFlow
that you may or may not want
to use for your project--
things like that.
So different limitations.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] what I
have [INAUDIBLE] with collab,
you can connect to
the [INAUDIBLE]..
YU-HAN LIU: Oh.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: In that
case, you can, right?
That's what you're saying?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
YU-HAN LIU: Right?
OK.
As opposed to the runtime
that's provided by this.
Cool, thank you.
Other questions or comments?
OK?
So where we were
was I was running
this auto-encoder
notebook, which,
I did click Run All, so I
just scrolled down and see,
OK, they ran, they seem OK, and
then scrolled all the way down
to the bottom.
I do see some outputs, OK?
It did run through
training for 20 epochs,
and showed a nice graph here.
And it's ultimately
[INAUDIBLE] so it's
trying to produce reconstructed
images of this [INAUDIBLE]..
So great, OK?
OK, now, I'm going to pretend
that I work on this code,
and then, now, it's time
to hand it off to someone.
What do I do?
I'm going to actually do a
little trick here and try
to make this, actually, a
Python script that's runnable.
I do want to keep the
notebook as a source,
because I used it
to experiment with.
But I don't want to
manually copy code out.
So I would use this tool called
nbconvert that many of you
might have used.
But in this case,
I think I do want
to be a little careful here.
So when I'm experimenting, I'm
going to run not 20 epochs,
because that could take a while.
So I'm going to run just
one epoch, let's say.
Just when I experiment.
And then, in a
graph, I'm to show--
or maybe two epochs, yeah, OK?
But then, when I'm
doing these, I'm
kind of getting
concerned because this
is a temporary change.
I'm not going to keep these
two epochs as hardcoded.
So I'm going to come
back up here and try
to introduce a parameter here.
I'm going to go all
the way up here right
below from future
import, because that
must be the first thing.
I'm going to try to make
this into an argument that
can be passed into, not
a notebook, but rather
the Python script that I'm going
to create with notebookconvert.
So I'm going to do something
like this into import argparse.
And then I'll have something
like this and that.
And I went to just the epochs
parameter that I can change.
So I'll just have
something like--
I'll have something
like optional epochs,
and with type of int with
a default of, say, 2, OK?
So once I have this,
and after, of course,
I want to read a parse args.
I don't remember if
it's no marks or--
names are on it, and then
rely on known_args, OK?
And then I'm going to parse that
so now this args variable holds
epochs, at least, right?
So let me run this
just to double-check.
All right, so it will
be this namespace that
has this thing called epochs.
That's two.
And later, I can pass
in different numbers
in the parameters.
So I'm going to go down here
to change those things now.
I'm not really interested in
training two epochs until--
I mean, once I'm out of the--
how do I mean?
Once I'm out of the local
experimentation mode,
I'm going to run
more epochs, and I'm
going to hit args_epochs, OK?
And replace the
other two as well.
Args-- OK.
OK, so that was OK.
And I'm going to
try and run this
after I do not become notebook
convert, and come out here,
clear.
And see, I have copied a copy
of the notebook out there.
And I really don't like to
keep two separate sources,
and so I'm going to call
this with python nbconvert.
There.
And I need to specify what
kind of output it is there.
It does a lot of
interesting things.
You can turn into a Markdown.
You can turn it into HTML.
JSON is, I think,
the basic format.
So I'm going to
turn it into Python.
Which file?
Auto-encoder, that notebook.
OK, write something.
Right?
So it's writing a number
of bytes to autoencoder.py,
and I see the file
showing up here.
Right now, it's
showing up here, OK?
And so now, I can run it.
I'm going to just run
Python 3, autoencoder.py,
and now I can pass in
an epoch parameter.
And let me say, let's train--
remember, my default
values was two.
I'm going to train four epochs.
Why not?
And now it basically runs in
some ways, One step at a time.
But there is a
little gotcha here
if you have not used
notebookconvert before.
If you used the magical
commands, magic commands,
instead of the cells, it
does not get converted.
And so those never run, OK?
Oh, my bad, because
args actually-- sorry,
let me go back and fix that.
Because I used the Parse
Known Arguments here.
And then, notice
that this args here
is really a two-pole of things.
One thing is the parameter
we're going to be parsing.
And the other
thing is this thing
that notebook just
carries along with it.
That's also part of why I
had to use parse known_args.
So I'm just going to ignore
the second part of it.
I run this again--
args now is just two, OK.
Then I'm going to run the same
command again, convert it--
so let me make it clearer here.
I'm going to run the convert--
which, again, takes the
current state of a notebook
and makes it into
a Python script--
and I'm going to
run it in python3,
autoencoder.py, it will
be after the conversion,
and I'm going to
pass in epochs 4, OK?
Oh, and sorry if my
screen turns yellow.
It's the night shift coming on.
OK, so now it's running.
And it has a little bit
noisier print-out here.
And then it's running first
epoch, second epoch, and so on.
On?
OK, that's great.
So now I have a
Python script they
I can supposedly run
wherever I want, OK?
Not quite, right?
I do know that this Python
script runs real well
in this Docker Container.
That's the mental model here.
I have the host someway.
I have a bunch of other
machines I might be able to use.
But I read don't know
if this script runs
anywhere except for this
particular container.
I know that it runs well here
it trains through for me.
It has a little bit easier with
showing the images because I'm
in shell, OK?
There's another problem here.
It also does not save the
model, which I neglected to do.
So let's go through this again.
I had an encoder, a decoder,
and I wanted to save the model.
So where was the training loop?
Here is the training loop.
I do want, by the
end of training,
right after the FOR loop,
I'm going to save the model.
So I have the model, Save.
Save the model for,
maybe, save format is TF.
I'm going to save that
as a TensorFlow save
model format, OK?
As opposed to the H5 format, OK?
So I have this and
then I would say,
that's a little
bit of gotcha here.
If I just run this, it will
complain I cannot save.
Let me just show you.
I'm running this notebook
here, and then I try to--
I have a data set.
If I just try to run
the training loop,
it's going to say I'm missing
some stuff, because it turns
out to save that TensorFlow--
save the model format.
Which is much better, sorry,
Which is really good in a way,
that it's much more portable.
It can you you to other--
it's more most
self-contained, so you
can deploy that for a
prediction more easily.
But it's complaining now.
It says it doesn't know.
It doesn't know.
It's saying that I should call
something like this, call step
inputs, because to save
that in that format
it needs to know
what input shape is.
Luckily, it's not too
difficult. The error message
here is very helpful.
It tells me, as you
call, set input, inputs--
I'm doing the pass
in the whole input.
I think that's called x_train.
And then, run this
again, only two epochs.
The default value here,
then you will save.
Pardon me, you will save
a saved_model format,
a saved_model for me.
And it's going to show up
on the left side here--
refresh.
And actually, it saved
the model directory.
And again, because we
mounted the volume.
And so that was like,
this is outside now.
So I come back-- out
again, that's in my house
machine on my Mac now.
I look at this, I see the
saved_model directory.
And I see what's inside of it.
It has assets.
It has saved_models.
Maybe just do this.
Where am I?
So it has the variables and
assets already saved for me.
Again, even if the
training process
was, running not on my
laptop directly, but rather
inside this container,
they could share, OK?
But let's see what
happens if I were
to try to run the same
command outside, right?
So I also have the converted
notebook and converted Python
script right outside here.
What if I sort of it?
I can do Python
3 autoencoder.py,
and it's going to fail right
away, because I don't have
any of the dependencies that
was installed in the container,
right?
So this is literally
the same script
because on the shared
volume, but running
on different machines.
That's the environment,
the different environment
or changing environment
that I was talking about.
And it has different
output, right?
So in a container, that's a
much more secure and consistent
environment.
Now, I know this script
here definitely runs.
If I handed the script
to someone else,
it would not work.
But if you hand them the
script along with the Docker
container, it will
work for them, OK?
Questions so far?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Do you
recommend sharing
a directory that [INAUDIBLE]?
YU-HAN LIU: I would think so.
So the question is, like,
maybe we should just
share the directory.
Yeah, so in some
cases, if you do have--
your team has the
infrastructure set
up so that you can have a shared
drive or something like that?
That would work pretty well.
One of our previous
teams, we did have a--
we'd have everything hosted
in the cloud, and so that way,
everything would be
already shared by default.
But that has other kinds
of issues because race a
again, so--
or versioning, right.
Other questions or comments?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Just for an example,
did you just save the weights,
or did you have--
YU-HAN LIU: Oh, in
this case, I used Save
and not Save Weights
because I was
saving as-- is that question?
Like, if you Save
Weights as opposed--
AUDIENCE: Yes.
YU-HAN LIU: In this
case, I just used Save,
but I specified the format
to be to be TensorFlow.
So that already has the
variables in it like this file
here.
Over here.
AUDIENCE: Did you have to find
weights, though, [INAUDIBLE]??
YU-HAN LIU: Predefined
weights, or--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: No,
for this notebook,
I think it just randomizes
the initial weights,
and it's only meant-- right.
But here, it saves the
weights after training.
So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] model it,
and [INAUDIBLE] model weight?
YU-HAN LIU: Right,
including model weight.
So if you save the model
directory, it's really nice.
This whole tree here, if you
hand this whole thing off,
you can really deploy
that, and other people
will be able to be able to
surf the model very easily.
But if will not just be easy
to pick it up and continue
your experiments.
That's sort of the
gotcha here as well.
So it's very self-contained.
It has the structure
of your graph,
and that's savedmodel.pb, and
it has the weights, the train
weights.
But if someone wants to
actually load that and continue
with experiments, or modify
the graph in some way,
that's a little bit trickier.
So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] data sets
in your container, as well,
or is that in the [INAUDIBLE]?
YU-HAN LIU: Thank
you, good question.
So how about data sets?
So in this case, in
this particular case,
there's one step here where
it downloads data set.
Where do I have it?
I think it's just [INAUDIBLE]
in this case, right?
So [INAUDIBLE] can
see it as well.
So there's a part where
you download the data set.
It just so happens that the
downloaded data set lives
on a container, but
not in a Home folder,
but somewhere in a
temporary directory.
So it will be gone once I
turn off the container, OK?
And so this is a small thing.
And keep in mind, if your mount
that, only the volume that's
been mounted over here.
Otherwise, not.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
So if I want to load the
model and train further epochs
beyond two, or beyond
four, I would not
be able to do it in this
format, is that right?
YU-HAN LIU: You still
can do it, but that's
why we actually changed to
allow the epochs parameter to be
passed from outside.
So you can change that.
But right now, it looks like I
can run it on my host, right?
Is that what you meant, or--
AUDIENCE: No, so I want to
train further epochs on it
and then to continue from where
I have trained it already.
YU-HAN LIU: Oh,
with saved_model,
I think you will have
some trouble with that.
AUDIENCE: All right, all right.
YU-HAN LIU: It's doable,
just a little bit more work.
And so in that case, you
might want to just save
that as a checkpoint.
AUDIENCE: OK.
YU-HAN LIU: Then it's
much easier to reload it.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
YU-HAN LIU: If you want
continue to the experiments.
AUDIENCE: What does the
checkpoints save, exactly?
Just the weights,
or more than that?
YU-HAN LIU: It also saves some
more than just the weights.
AUDIENCE: But what else?
YU-HAN LIU: But somehow
interface is setup,
so it's easier to reload
back into TensorFlow, so--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: Hmm?
YU-HAN LIU: It does save the--
well, not the training
data, for sure.
It does save the weights
and the model architecture--
so the graph itself, as well.
But using slightly
different format.
So you should really
think of this Save
the Model format as some
sort of a serialized format.
So that's transportable
to other places.
But for a checkpoint,
you still need
to get this stuff with
different purposes.
With checkpoints, you doing
the-- the executive purpose is
to resume training, and so you
do need a copy of your code
where--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE],,
but your point
is a runtime status
of [INAUDIBLE]??
YU-HAN LIU: Yes, if
you set things up so.
So I'm a little concerned
about saying that it's
the runtime status of that.
It's not everything, though.
So in some cases, when I set
things up, some of the layers
might lose their
parameters and things
like that batch norms that carry
some of the hidden parameters.
Normally, you will
keep those as well.
But yes, it's sort of like
in the middle training
what's the state right now, so
that we can continue later on.
And save the model is
more of, all right,
I'm done with training.
I want to save a copy I can give
it to someone else to serve.
And that's good for
that purpose because it
is faster than reloading
from a checkpoint
and the serve is very slow.
So they different purposes, OK?
Other questions or comments?
I do want to have at least
five more minutes of your time.
Or do we go on until
8 o'clock, or--
8:30?
AUDIENCE: 8:30, yeah.
YU-HAN LIU: Good, thank you.
So we can go a little bit more.
I do want to show you the
Docker file, at least, right?
So we've done all this work.
What for, exactly, right?
Unless I get us
to point where we
have a package that I
can hand to someone.
OK, so this is great.
Now what?
I have something that
I can run, but only
in this specific container.
But I [INAUDIBLE] sort
of separate, right?
I have this container
that happens
to be running on my machine.
That's great.
But then, this script here that
lives outside cannot be run,
right?
Cannot really stand
alone because I have cut
the connection between the
code and the environment.
I have the Docker
file already built,
so I'm going to show you.
It's called Docker
File, no surprise.
OK, it looks just like this.
It's not very much.
It says, I'm starting
from something, right?
That's the base
container, which happens
to be the container
that I was running.
Sorry, that's the image I was
running of this container.
That serves a notebook, right?
So that's where
all the experiments
was happening-- the
notebook, the Jupyter server.
And when it started from
there, at that point.
let me copy this code here,
copy this thing that's
the real outcome of your hard
work, the thing that actually
runs.
Now, these two together
completes the bottom edge
of the triangle I
was talking about.
There's code that works
in that environment.
So now, this is a
pretty complete bundle
that I can hand it to anyone
now and they can just run.
And now I'll say, OK, so
this is the run command that
says every time when I run this
container which I'm building
on top of this
other base container
that I had before right, right?
I literally took the container
that someone else published
on the internet, I downloaded
it, do some experiments,
and created a piece of
code that can run on it.
And then I say,
OK, now I'm going
to do something on top of
that includes my work now, OK?
So I'm just going to build it.
So I'll say docker build.
Good habit here-- so
when I build Docker,
I actually always use a tag.
I'm just going to tag
it like, tfworld--
why not?
And then put a dot here, which
means the current directory,
because I need to specify the--
what's the word?
The context when you
build the Docker.
So that means everything
in here is fair game.
And so that basically
specifies, these
are the files I might
be interested in when
I build my own Docker image
for myself or others to use.
So they start here.
It really is the
current directory.
And you will look for, in that
directory, a Docker file, which
I have, and to build it.
And so I'm going to build it.
You will-- oh, I hope it
doesn't download the thing.
No, it does not.
OK, so you see, it does
not try to download
this whole this
six-gigabyte monster here
because I had done
that once before.
And it's all this--
that's why it took such
a small amount time.
All it does is
literally copy this file
into it at a
specified entry point
so that I get the wrong command.
OK, so now if I clear
it and docker images--
remember, this lists all
the images I have here--
I should see the image
that's called tfworld.
It's right here now.
I just built, OK?
So it has very little,
really, the delta
between that and this
other Docker base image
that other people published.
It's the only difference is just
that one file that we created
and entry point specification.
Now I can run it.
Now this is an image
that's packaged
with the correct
dependencies in place.
Let's run it.
So I will say
docker run tfworld.
And what will happen
is that it will load up
this image, my new image--
which, again, has
all dependencies
because that starts
from something--
and it'll try to run a file.
When I run it this way,
it will just run it
with the default parameters.
So you should train two epochs,
because that's what we said.
And now you see that it's
downloading the data again.
So every time when
I run it, I will
have to re-download the
app, because that was not
part of my Docker file.
So if you want, you will do
something additional here
in the Docker file
and say, somehow,
download training data,
perhaps, in some way,
so that you don't have
to always re-download it.
And then, now you're
starting out-- again,
the environment is
actually this other thing,
this Docker container
that happens
to be supported by my laptop as
the base hardware, if you like.
So you train two
epochs, hit done, right?
So that's exactly
what we expected.
And I'm running into the same
notice, showing the picture,
showing the graphs issue.
And what if I want to
train more epochs here?
Maybe try three.
So then it should run
the same thing again,
but now, you'll
notice that you'll
have to re-download it because
the previous docker run
command has exited already.
And so everything else is gone--
the download data,
the saved model
that was in there is also gone
because I did not mount volume,
right?
Notice that here, when
I said docker run,
I did not mount volume anymore.
So whatever is
created in the process
running the container
is totally gone now.
And this time around, you
just trained three epochs.
Any questions, by
the way, or comments?
OK, so you trained three
epochs, and it's done.
And I'm not sure why it's not
printing the error message
anymore.
Oh, it does.
It's just up here, OK?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: Performance?
YU-HAN LIU: I would say
just by the way it works,
it should be slower because
it's an additional layer
of communication
that's going on.
But I don't have hard numbers
to say how much slower it is.
I don't-- I haven't experienced
too much of slowdown myself,
unless there's a lot of
communication between
your container with the host
or your container with other
things.
Otherwise, this is a
whole process that's
running in itself, right?
So if you can somehow limit
to networking or disk I/O,
I don't think it should
be too big an issue.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is there [INAUDIBLE]?
So instead of running it
from scratch, [INAUDIBLE]..
YU-HAN LIU: Right,
which you already have,
maybe, on your host
machine, let's say.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
So they'd have to do the
checkpoint set quickly
and the Docker container
that they made [INAUDIBLE]??
YU-HAN LIU: You could
set things up this way.
So a couple different
options, right?
If you were to have that
on your host machine,
you can choose to--
depending on use
case, perhaps, you
can choose to copy
other stuff in here.
So on in the text editor
here, I could say something
like I can copy a checkpoint
into, also, home directory.
In that case, whatever
you have currently
at the time of building the
image on your host machine
will be moved into it.
So that's one way to do
it, though it contains
a copy for your starting point.
Another way to do it it this
does not serve your needs,
you might, again,
mount a volume.
Maybe sometimes,
you'll run it on.
But then, again,
mounted volume means
you need to remember to
carry that mounted volume
with you if you want to
move it somewhere else.
So that's a trade-off, yeah.
And on that point about
changing the Docker
file to do more
things, if you have
other dependencies you
might also run here,
it's very flexible.
It's literally
like you are inside
of a shell, except
you need to tell it
with your special keyword.
May I put RUN pip
install, a TensorFlow data
set, for example.
Something like this is which
is not really in the image,
but somehow you want
to use it, you can just
run this only one time.
The first time, when
you build this image,
you will have to literally run
this for you in that Docker
image and then just freeze that,
and it'll be there forever.
Questions?
OK?
Let's see.
I have a couple different
choices I can go from here.
Let me show you how to run the
same training somewhere else.
By going through all this
work, there's a purpose for it.
The purpose it,
really, that I really
don't want to train for
200 epochs on my laptop.
Also, not in a
Docker container that
happens to be running
on my laptop, right?
That just doesn't make sense.
Everyone's training on some
kind of cloud services.
And so this is the whole
package that you can literally
put it and give it to
some cloud service,
and it'll train for you.
But there's a catch
out there, and everyone
should think about
it before you really
do that, in that, where is
the output going to go, right?
Like locally, if I
mount things carefully,
running on my host machine
or inside of a container,
it doesn't matter that
much as long as I remember
to mount the volume, right?
The output will be
on my laptop still.
But if you're training
in some machine,
that whole machine
would be gone.
There's some machine
in the cloud.
And so you need to remember
to make the changes properly.
So let me actually
just quickly add in
in a couple of lines of
code to make it happen.
I'm going back to
his notebook here.
Remember, before we're
adding the arguments, right?
So to make it more flexible,
we allowed ourselves a number
of epochs, which,
assuming I'm going
to use some cloud
compute resource,
I'll train 200 epoch instead.
Let me add another one.
I'll say, model directory,
default to some just--
default to just local, right?
So something like this, OK?
And what's that going to
do, is that you will--
or a little bit
more, and I need to--
now, if I run this, you will
have the args will carry that,
as well, for me,
model directory,
or whatever passing at runtime.
I'm going to pass
different things, right?
By passing things, I mean
something like this, remember?
We were allowed to pass
whatever on the left-side side
of the screen.
Now I can pass in
additional parameters there.
Oh, see, if I'm just
running this Python script,
I also remembered
that what do I want?
Why do I want that?
I want to write.
Where am I?
I'm trying to save the model.
There we go.
I'm trying to save the
model to a good place, OK?
So I'm going to do
some path join here,
and I'll have args
model directory.
And I'm going to, in
the model directory,
have a saved model
directory that contains
the saved model, OK?
Actually, let's just
see how this should
make a difference for us.
I save, I go out here
and convert again
because, until I
actually convert,
that change I made exists
only in the notebook.
There's a single source, right?
So the whole thing with this
notebook convert is that.
OK, it's really quick,
so it's done already.
And so now my Python script
outside of the container,
my host, also has been changed.
If I remember, that
Python script doesn't run,
so I have to build again.
It doesn't run on my
host as it is, right?
So even if it has changed.
Right, so it has just changed
a few seconds ago At 7:53,
but so it contains the change
we just made of adding in this--
in order to save it.
But it doesn't run
until I build it, right?
Again, reminding
you what happened
here was my host machine simply
doesn't have the dependencies
to run this script.
But when I built
the image, I can.
So docker build
again, tfworld, dot.
And it-- oh, oops, I think I
kept the install TensorFlow
data sets.
So it could take
a couple seconds.
So I also installed
TensorFlow data sets now.
So it installed it.
So if I had to use that
in my training script,
now it can be used in
this environment as well.
And then you successfully
built-- forget about the red.
Don't worry about it.
It does copy the most
recent version of that now.
So we can do this now.
So check I have what stuff
I'm going to run docker run--
where's my docker run for me?
Docker run, and we
can now additionally
pass in the different
model directory.
I'm going to call it
output and then run it.
Now it's running
this updated script
that has this additional ability
or flexibility of saving--
it saved the model to somewhere
that I specified called output.
And that's the way it goes.
It could be [INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE] what I
think about this.
Any questions or comments
while we're waiting for this?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] something
like a job in a container that
is like a [INAUDIBLE]?
YU-HAN LIU:
[INAUDIBLE] then they
had these networking
issues here.
So that's.
So [INAUDIBLE].
To me, personally, it
feels like too much work
to figure out myself.
So I was probably go
looking at Kubernetes.
That already has networking,
It could speed it up for me.
Because I'm just really lazy.
I was just trying to
find cloud services,
but I already have those
that picked it up for me.
So I think that
multiple cloud services
do have similar things already.
So you'll be able say,
[INAUDIBLE] manuscript
on the master, just use--
I'll give you a for orders.
Normally, those things
should be handled for you,
and that's-- data scientists
such as yourself shouldn't be
worried about that.
That's my recommendation.
But if you have
appetite for that,
you might try to figure
things out yourself.
OK, it does not save here
because I did not put it
in the correct place, right?
It's running in-- still
not in the Home folder.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: Is it
possible to do what?
AUDIENCE: If you're going to do
it, it depends on [INAUDIBLE]??
YU-HAN LIU: If every
time when I do a--
AUDIENCE: Every time it
creates an item [INAUDIBLE]??
YU-HAN LIU: Every time
you create, it get bigger?
Maybe not.
So you mean like the
nbconvert [INAUDIBLE]??
AUDIENCE: Yes.
YU-HAN LIU: And then--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: [INAUDIBLE].
But I think that
makes a good point.
Over time, you can do this
multiple times, right?
Either I can make some
changes or testing it
on the outside on post.
[INAUDIBLE]
[INAUDIBLE] nbconverts with
mount these directories,
and then rebuild my
image for [INAUDIBLE]..
So eventually, you'll do that.
So just take away all
these manual steps.
All right, now, this, I would
do things slightly differently.
Each time I run a command,
I selected home slash output
as the model directory.
Now, remember, home
directory is mounted,
and so it's coming to
my local directory.
So I expect to see--
oh, I expect to see.
Oh, yes, I do, I do see.
I do see the saved the
model directory now.
No, [INAUDIBLE] is not, right?
It's--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: No, that's
from before, isn't it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: Right,
I ran it before.
I'm not sure why
it didn't show up.
AUDIENCE: You didn't mount it.
You didn't mount it [INAUDIBLE].
YU-HAN LIU: Oh I didn't
mount it when I ran it?
Thank you.
So thank you, just make sure
everybody else saw that.
This is a mistake I made here.
This is the gotcha,
number one gotcha.
Apparently, I still don't
remember myself all the time.
I did say that, yes,
after your work is done,
save the model to somewhere.
But that somewhere is gone
now because I didn't connect
that with the host machine.
So let's do it again, but
it's maybe with a fewer epochs
so we don't weight for it.
One, but in the wrong
command actually mounted.
A mounted, again, the syntax
is that host directory, colon,
the content of the directory.
So like this.
Oh, sorry, I also do want
to go into home to be sure.
There.
OK, any other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: Oh, I just meant
in the name of the directory
to put [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: Taking
a look at the code
here just to clarify that point.
Maybe I too quickly did that.
So here, the output
is passed into us
this argument here, which is
used as the prefix of the path
to write output to.
OK, so it's trained one
epoch, as we specified,
and now I see this directory
called output that has
the thing that's just created.
Right?
So it has-- inside
of it, there's
only one directory called
saved_model, because that's
what I told you to do.
I had, whatever you are
given as a model directory,
create another level
called save the model,
and that's the
saved_model bundle there.
Yeah, OK, so it looks
like this now, yeah.
OK?
Now, while we're
going through this,
once again,
backtracking, the reason
why we're adding this additional
power to the Pythons group
is that so I can save it
to wherever I want now.
Now, imagine if I had access to
some cloud computing resources.
I could just say, run
this container for me
with whatever
resources you have,
but write output to some kind
of cloud storage solution.
But if we can do that, so I do
want to show that real quick.
Maybe it's five
more minutes and we
can go into all just
more general Q&A,
is that I do need to push
this image here, right?
So once again, Docker
images, all these images
are things that exist on
my local machine only.
In particular, this thing
here, this package here, now, A
can be run wherever
that can run Docker.
B accepts an epochs
parameter, so I
can specify a large number of
epochs if I wanted to, and C,
it also accepts additional
model directory parameters,
so I can save the output
to somewhere else.
So let's say you should
try to push that.
I'm going to use Google
AI platform's training,
but only because I
have access to that.
And I have a cheat
sheet here for myself.
I remember the command
of how to push an image.
OK, here's what I'll have to do.
Test, push-- OK.
A little trickier.
I need to rebuild it
with a different tack.
I think different services
do things differently.
If you you use
Docker Hub, I think
you need to use the
tooling, too, to push.
And then you specify
your tag different ways.
I'm going to rebuild
the same image
and call it AI Things 101 TF
in Docker, because why not?
I'm going to build it.
Oh, I'm in the wrong directory.
You see, what's
happening here is
that it's trying to look
for a file called "docker
file" in where I am right now.
But remember, I just
changed directory
into the output directory,
which it doesn't have it, right?
It has only [INAUDIBLE].
Do it again.
Build with this.
And nicely, it
becomes a new tag.
Luckily, it's very quick, again,
only because, literally, I'm
just renaming it.
OK, now I have this
new image here.
Just double-check there.
Images, I see it
somewhere up here.
This is a tag.
And I'm looking for
something that's
created just seconds ago.
So maybe change it on the--
oops.
Docker one.
I want to see that, see that
thing that I just created.
OK, so successfully tagged.
Docker images, do I see it?
Do I see this one?
No.
Oh, see, I was a
little worried when
you said eight minutes ago.
Why did you say
eight minutes ago?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YU-HAN LIU: Because nothing
has changed in the past eight
minutes, right?
So Docker handles
that for you as well.
If any of the files that
you copy into that image
has changed, it will
rebuild that for you.
If nothing has changed, it
will just use the cache.
So you don't have to
think about, oh, have I--
just always run it.
You will get the most--
the current state of things.
If nothing has
changed, you will not
be wasting time, wasting
your time doing work either.
And then I have secretly
on my cheat sheet here,
also, the push command.
There's a bunch of other stuff
just so that I can access that,
but feel free to ignore that.
I need to authenticate.
I don't have key file.
Let's see if that works still.
You might work just the same.
And I'm going to push, I'm
going to run Docker Push
this image here to somewhere.
See, now, there is tech here.
The tech I use, which looks
really long right before I just
called TF world, which is
super easy to remember.
Why do I need this long
and messy gcr.io and so on?
Because it gets parsed.
And so gcloud command knows
where to put that thing into.
Just to be sure, let me
push the one that says one.
No, let me push the
same one, just so
you it doesn't take too long.
OK, so it's going to push.
Oh, and I'm afraid it could
take some time because I also
did install--
sorry, did install
TensorFlow data sets just
now, which is additional
data to upload.
OK, pushed.
And see hold this bunch of stuff
here, layer already exists?
What are those layers?
Those are the base layers--
six gigabytes of stuff
which I previously
had pushed before
so it doesn't get
re-pushed because there's
no need for that.
And Docker internally
is using these hashes
to identify individual
layers, right?
Now it's, oh, I
see this hash here.
Let me look for it in all the
past pushed layers before.
If something already
existed, there's no need to.
They could just come
here, booting from here.
OK, so it's pushed away, is it?
It's pushed to this
directory here.
It's on Google-- so I'm
in a console now for GCP.
And I have container registry.
And for this project, I have
a TF in Docker repository,
and it has a few images.
And then, the one that we just
pushed is over here just now.
So it's just pushed, OK?
And so this is [INAUDIBLE].
So you think of this sort
of like a Docker Hub.
So now, if you
have a teammate who
manages running
of experiments, I
mean while you are exploring
and designing experiments,
someone else handles running
for you, you can just say,
here it is, now try
to run it for me
with whatever infrastructure you
have-- maybe run hyperparameter
tuning if you want, things
like that, which you can just
create a large number of them.
And I'm going to copy
this image name here,
which is pretty messy, right?
It has all the hash at the end.
But there's a value in that.
So that specifies exactly
this copy of image
so that the result
really can be reproduced.
And I'm going to run it in a--
I'm going to paste in here.
Again, this is my cheat sheet.
I already have the commands
already written down.
But we can talk about
this a little bit.
So what I'm trying to do is I'm
going to use gcloud command.
Again, I tried to run a
training job on my AI platform
because I don't want
to run it on my laptop.
I'm going to give it a name
called something, TF world.
I'm going to submit
a training job
in a certain compute region.
I want to turn around
compute resources there.
And then, here's an
interesting flag here--
master image URI.
That ties back to the
question you had before,
whether you have
masters and workers.
You can even have
different images
for a whole cluster of
machines if you want.
But here, I'm just saying I
only want one machine that
runs this particular
thing, and I'm
going to specify my model
directory to be a Google Cloud
Storage location, TF in Docker,
maybe do you have Docker one,
why not, just for TF world.
And then, run three epochs.
And I'm going to run this
command and see what happens.
I'm going to run it.
It's only three epochs,
so it's not very long,
but in the real
situation, you'd probably
run it for 300 or something.
OK, so here's
command runs again.
Oh, it's not formatted
correctly, property.
So I'm running, I'm
submitting a training job,
and the only description
of the job is just,
I don't even upload code
anymore because I had already
done that.
I'm just saying, run
this container for me
with these parameters, and I
expect reproducible results.
And it says queued.
OK, queued where?
It's not running in my laptop.
It's running wherever
I submit the job to,
which is on the
AI platform here,
now you see this job is running.
We're going there and looking
at logs, although there's not
a whole lot of CPU.
We have seen that many
times this evening already.
It's going to be exactly the
same thing, because literally,
all this does is that it's
going to try to secure
some compute resources
for me and then run things
like that container.
And because the whole
environment is carried over,
every dependency that we have
used in two different ways,
the local Jupyter lab, when
I was doing experimentation,
that's in the environment.
And then, when I was testing
the scripts outside of here,
that's the exact
same environment.
And furthermore, here, this
online, in-the-cloud training
job, that's when
I'll need, yet again,
the very same environment there.
So I should expect that
to happen very soon.
Any questions how this works?
Or comments?
And if you use Kubernetes,
if you already-- maybe you
and your team already have,
say, a Kubernetes cluster
already set up.
You have multiple nodes that's
compute resources for you
to use.
You can deploy this as well.
That's, again, one
package that can
be moved wherever you
want, minus training data,
unless you do things
carefully as well.
But otherwise, [INAUDIBLE].
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so say you
have a very large data set.
Could you have
multiple containers
running processing one part of
the data set and [INAUDIBLE]
and have that data
[INAUDIBLE] the output?
I mean, what would that
workflow look like?
Because I imagine--
YU-HAN LIU: Yeah, you can
totally do something like that.
So the question is, what
if you have a large data
set and you want to process
different parts in parallel,
perhaps?
you don't care if one part
is processed or trained first
before another.
You can also--
again, you don't want
to create the same code for
different worker jobs there.
You might this is something
I was trying to do.
I was adding on the end
again, another argument here.
I'll say something like,
data directory or something,
that I can additionally pass in.
And in that way, when I spun
up different containers,
I could just pass them
different directory targets.
Maybe they are different
directories containing a lot
of TensorFlow files-- or
TensorFlow record files,
sorry--
things like that.
And then, I can just,
you know, pass the scene.
That way, when I create
a new container process,
again, in the exact
same environment,
the only thing I
want to change is
they process different portions
of the data, different shards
of data.
I can pass this in.
OK, probably because
of TensorFlow world,
it's not running.
But I do want to
show you that what
happens when this does work
is that I expect to see a--
right?
What did we pass in before?
I passed in this as a target
location to the write,
to save the model out to.
AI things slash TensorFlow
in Docker, TF [INAUDIBLE]..
This is AI Think's
bucket, and in here, I
expect to see a new
directory being created
that contains the
saved_model when
the job completes and exits,
if if it would just run.
Normally, it wouldn't
take that long.
You see, in my
previous experiments,
it usually takes-- oh, it's
up to 10 minutes before it
completes, but I think the
actual running takes some time.
So what's happening here is
that I specified this new Docker
identifier.
Remember this long,
ugly string here
that has this whole hash
number and everything?
So the infrastructure
in the infrastructure
does have to pull that, the
thing I just uploaded somehow.
So it's pulling that,
and I tried to run it.
But we can just let it
run, and then later, we'll
see what happens.
But I think that about
concludes everything
I want to show you
for this evening.
Why don't we switch to a more
of a chatting Q&A session,
if you like?
And it's pretty late.
If you have other
business to attend to,
feel free to go attend to them.
And I'll be here until 8:30
if you want to chat with me.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: That's great.
[APPLAUSE]
YU-HAN LIU: Oh, I'm sorry.
It's finished.
Thank you.
So look, that's finished.
Let's actually go here
and really quickly see--
make sure it saves the file.
And now it does save.
It just created this
thing here, and that
has the saved_model for me.
And so, again, in a
checkpoint kind of scenario,
you'll write the
checkpoints, also,
out until someone's storage
so that your team can
come in and, maybe,
evaluate, maybe
figure out how to
deploy, maybe continue
your experiment for you.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]